uh welcome everybody so I'm going to be
talking about intake and I'll tell you
what that is for people that don't know
and uh perhaps we have some old fans of
intake around with us too so intake take
two version two 0000 Alpha is indeed
very Alpha this is experimental new
version of intake you don't need to know
anything about what intake is to follow
this talk so um here are some links
these will be in the uh in the slides so
you can come back to this uh you can
install take two right now uh you can
follow along the documentation there's a
massive PR in which all of this code
lives and I'm going to try and make this
as Simple and Clean as possible no
flashy slides no animations not really
even any graphics let's get going so
just quickly about me I work for
anaconda anaconda has a group that works
explicitly on open source software
that's what I do and I've been doing
this for quite long time so you might
have heard of some of the projects that
I'm involved in like uh fspec and uh
dask and things that are quite well
known um I'm happy to talk about those
but intake itself has been around for a
number of years and this is a major
rewrite I'm going to tell you about
today so um brief outline of the talk um
where does intake fit in what is the
data landscape like specific Niche I'm
in aing at uh some code I'm going to run
for you and then a summary of the
features that are current and in
development and followed by this is
really the point of the talk a request
for feedback I want to know if people
think this is going in the right way I
want people to try it out look at the
documentation think about whether you
can use intake in your day-to-day data
Journeys or not and I want to hear from
everybody so that will include in the
chat right now live in the conference
Discord and of course on GitHub where
the code is actually happening or just
get in contact with me all of these are
good okay so uh we're at Pi data so we
care about Python and we care about data
in particular we usually care about open
source software that's what I do it's
what a lot of us do and uh even more
people use open source software in their
day-to-day python data analysis or
whatever it is that you might be doing
to do stuff with data you usually go
through a bunch of steps these will
involve getting some bytes from
somewhere turning those bytes into
in-memory objects calling some functions
some API on those objects that does
Computing for you maybe you're making
models maybe you're making plots or
inferences you're making some kind of
output from all of these things and
maybe you'll go through this cycle a few
times now this being uh open source
software there are lots of tools that
you can use for each of these steps um
but something that is usually dropped
that is not talked about very much you
won't really see this in the other talks
at this conference is how do we know
which data to get how do we know which
is the right data set to solve the thing
that you're doing and how do we know for
that particular data set how you ought
to go about loading it and doing stuff
with it usually you'll just see code
you'll see something like this this is a
very typical first cell of some notebook
or script or or
application and this is the kind of
thing that people will tend to copy and
paste this is not real code but your
code probably looks like this there'll
be a bunch of imports there'll be so uh
there'll be some definitions of things
there'll be some function calls maybe
you need to call some package loading
function maybe you need to download the
the data in the first place maybe you
need to clean the data eventually after
all of this stuff you end up with
something that you can actually use to
do your analysis do the work that as a
data practitioner you want to do so all
the rest of this stuff is basically just
getting in the way um it's important to
get right though because otherwise you
won't be able to do your work uh maybe
in your day-to-day work all you actually
uses band. RSV but usually it's more
complicated than that and even if you
have all the this stuff you still don't
know except for the URL that you happen
to be loading from is this the right
data set there's no description there's
there's nothing built in here you have
to know you have to Faithfully copy and
paste so uh in the data landscape there
are many many things out there there are
stuff to keep hold of your files and
byes there's stuff for tracking versions
there's stuff for listing data sets in
some API some database some Warehouse
some some data Lake whatever it may be
loads of things for pipelining for
workflows for explor expert but there's
there's loads of things that you can do
there's only one I mention here data set
is particularly well loved by the
community because it says hey everything
can be a SQL like database which is kind
of cool if all of your data can be a SQL
light database but not all data is
tabular so intake is kind of simplistic
intake doesn't store your data it has no
server you don't register on a thing it
isn't it doesn't provide Enterprise
security or or your catalogs can live
wherever you put them and this
Simplicity is throughout everything that
intake does I haven't said yet what it
does so you're going to see that in a
moment um we're not going to do although
it's declarative we're going to declare
our data sets we're not going to be
editing yaml and lots of nice pointand
click interface elements will be coming
in the
future um so that's a that's a kind of
long description of of what intake is
but I should say it's basically about
describing your data
sets what data sets do you have access
to what are those data sets how do you
load them this is this is the niche that
we're going for now I'm going to
demonstrate it with some code in a
moment uh you notice there's no flashy
anything here that that's my style but
it's also the intake style keep
everything to the minimum uh for those
of you that have seen V1 so the existing
released intake that has been around for
a few years there's lots of changes
compared to that and uh maybe we'll have
a little time for question and answers
at the end about why I made those
changes and and why they're important
but uh I I'm trying to reach a wider
audience than the current V1 users so uh
let's get stuck into little bit of
code okay so uh this like I say is all
pretty dry this is a programmatic way in
which you can build a data catalog and
it's all pretty simple there's actually
lots of ways with uh V2 intake take two
that you can create catalog entries
here's one way that you might go about
it so here's the URL and a panda's load
CSV this is read CSV just happens to be
the most common thing that people do but
actually there's loads of different
functions with which you might load your
data this is just the one that's
probably most familiar to people um
having made this call this is the call
that you might have made in your
original notebook um it can take that
call and guess what you mean so it can
encode it into this reader object we can
look at this reader object and no
surprise this is a CSV reader
it knows it's going to produce a pandas
data frame and the your arguments are in
here so here is your url here is the
fact that we know this is going to be
anonymous we have something we're going
to use some columns all that stuff is in
there so it's trivial in this case and
for many cases actually uh intake is
good at recognizing a number of
different loading functions and you can
automatically encode it into a thing
that's not the only way that you can
roduce this thing another way if you
don't know that you that this is CSV if
you don't know that you need to use
pandas or you might be able to use
pandas you can actually say hey intake
what kind of file does this look like it
looks like a CSV file this shouldn't be
a surprise the URL contained the CSV
that's a simple case but actually intake
can guess a lot of things by Magic bytes
and there are a lot of data types that
are encoun counted by intake and also
data services so uh files are not the
only thing that we handle then you can
say oh okay it's a CSV so I'm going to
make a data object out of this this is
this thing is this thing so that was
kind of automatic and I can ask what are
the things that I can build from this or
equivalently what are the things that
can read this you can see well there's
quite a few things that can read csvs
that's not a surprise um one of them is
not importable spark I don't happen to
have in this environment but for all of
the others we have these you have a
class and we have the thing that it's
going to make so we can read it with
geop pandas pandas duck DB Ray dask
array binary reader it's interesting
this one is not is is not a CSV reader
it's just going to give you the bytes of
the file and a simple python bytes
reader and a even simpler does this file
exist reader which is interesting one
because that's just going to give you a
true or false there is an ordering here
the ones that are specific to csvs come
first and the ones that are generic
across Files come
afterwards so um if we call this on the
data this is the same thing that we did
before this reader is equivalent to the
one that uh intake initially guessed up
here exactly the same um the definition
of the reader is super simple uh this
means that people can build their own
and that is the point here you can make
as many of these as you like uh the
current version of the code already
includes dozens of these and that's
because the definitions that you need to
get this off the ground are very minimal
we know this D pandas that just tells
you it's going to need to be able to
import pandas to do anything it works on
CSV files
only um it calls this function pandas
read CSV and for this function the thing
that is the the URL is actually known as
file PA or B that's that's knowing
something about the third party library
and this bit you don't even need this
just says if you want to read just the
first few lines of your data then you
need to add this keyword argument and
you need to make sure that these two
keyword arguments aren't there that's
something that people with domain
knowledge about the third party package
could do okay that's all waffle you
don't need to know that stuff what you
need to know is the API of the reader is
super simple you can do read and here's
my data it's a the most minimalistic um
data set that you're going to see and
this is less than a toy it's trivial uh
but it's it's fine it's interesting that
you can just do read and you can do this
on any type of of uh reader. read will
give you the thing you can also have
access to documentation we're not going
to read this this is just the Panda's
read CSV documentation if you need to
know all the keyword arguments you can
use but there are some more interesting
things here like what can I do with this
I can transform it into all kinds of
other things um I can apply uh data
frame selection for example is a really
obvious thing that you might want to do
to a a data frame um and I have access
to the data frame API so lots of you
know these are all the pandas methods
that you might do to a data frame and
the point of doing all of this I so have
a specific namespace of Panda's
functions the point of all of this is
that I can encode new readers based on
the previous reader using just the
exactly the same pandas uh syntax as you
would have done would use in your normal
code and this works for any third-party
package so I can build a bunch of
these and I can look at one of these and
basically what I've done or maybe let's
just view one of
these
actually to see what this is so this
these are pipelines and it says I'm
going to do pandage read CSV that's
going to make me a data frame I'm going
to select a which is just the column
selection I'm going to do string to it
the the string accessor and do
capitalize and all of these produce
pandas output and I can persist these
now I have a catalog this catalog has a
number of data sets in um defined in it
and I can call these this catalog is the
thing that you will be dealing with it's
a thing that you share with other people
and uh you can just use dot access or
square bracket access or whatever it is
and every single one of these data sets
has Associated descriptions and metadata
stuff that in this case I haven't yet
filled out but you can do and also
includes the original data description
so this is the this is the thing this is
the the Nugget that everything is
working off is that we know that there
is the CSV thing and it exists with
these
arguments okay um what do I do with this
I can save this to a place or here is
one that I've saved to a public place
that everybody here can access if you
want to run this code yourself I can
just say I want to load this catalog now
I have a new version of the catalog this
is exactly the same as what I had before
I can tab complete and there there is my
my tutorial reader or I can I could
select one of these and and I I can read
it this uh inverted if you were not
following this just change the order of
the two rows here not very
exciting um I could do some more
interesting things to it though so you
know probably how to go from a panda's
data frame to a plot but there are some
nice utility things uh you can always
look at the dot
transform to see what things are defined
as I showed you above I could call these
things I can say I want to convert my
data frame to a hollow views plot if you
know what Holo views is this just runs
and there's some you not very exciting
plot uh with a whole load of options
that I'm not going to bother changing
here or equivalently I can say hey I
want to make a m plot Li plot and there
is that so these convenience things are
really handy and this thing without the
do read I could persist that into a
catalog too all of these things are
readers so I can keep as many elements
of my pipeline as I like including
output if I want to save this into a
different format for
example furthermore um intake can guess
these path paths for me if I say hey I
want to start with this data thing this
CSV thing or I could have put the URL in
here by itself which you know is easy to
guess it's a CSV in this case but it
also works for lots of other things and
I want to make a BNG out of it now I
have that that's inhibit right how do I
go from a data thing to an image thing
well one way and this is the shortest
way so intake is going to guess but
there are ways of seeing what what are
all of the possibilities of going from
CSV to image but an obvious way is to
you know basically do exactly the same
as I just did before uh read it with
pandas go to a map plot figure and then
save that M plot Li figure using this
converter and there are loads of these
so I got to show you the the the web of
things that intake currently understands
but this is ever increasing there's if
you want to transform your data if you
want to convert it from one thing to
another you probably don't have to think
too hard about how to do that intake is
going to know what all the pieces are
and if those pieces don't exist they're
really really easy to
add okay final thing for my presentation
here is
um in the original definition def I had
this this data object maybe I just show
you this again what is
the this belongs in this piece so what
is this data object it's uh just knows
that it's a CSV and that it has this URL
and that it's Anonymous access um and
this is saved into the catalog too so I
could have got this from the
catalog I've been using pandas all this
time but I already showed you that
intake knows this can be read with a
whole bunch of different things so why
why not use one of those this is really
easy to do I can
say I might happen to know how to write
out the code to read a CSV with dask
it's not that complicated but I can use
intake to guess how to do these things
for you so I can say hey I want to read
this with dask or hey I want to read
this with Ray you can do that too um and
these are not like the the apis of dask
and Ray are not the same so you would
need to do a little bit of digging to to
do this automatically for yourself to
figure out what code you need to run but
intake just knows all this stuff for you
so it's super handy and again this thing
this reader the ray reader for this CSV
data is something that you can put into
a catalog this catalog could contain the
panda path the dask path the ray path or
side by side if you want so that the
user when they read your catalog can
decide for themselves which of these is
the one that I actually want to use
because they might happen to have a desk
cluster or they might happen to have
array cluster or spark or whatever it is
and you as the data provider or even you
to yourself don't need to force their
hand you don't need to say hey this is a
package that integrates with desk only
and nothing else you don't need to make
those choices anymore uh and just the
final one just for fun you can say hey I
want to read this with desk and actually
I want to run it on Ray so desk on Ray
is a thing for those that haven't seen
this uh these two outputs because I
haven't actually like this is a lazy
object here I haven't done compute or I
haven't actually asked for the values
yet these look very similar but the
second version is using the dask API to
call Ray which is an interesting thing
that you might want to do okay that was
a fair amount of um executing lines of
code and uh uh whistle stops tore of
lots of things that you can do with uh
intake but let's do a short summary uh
what does all of this mean okay so
intake allows you to describe your data
you can say this is a CSV or this is a
SQL API end point and query or this is
a a tiled Sero or is this is a stack
catalog these are all things that intch
knows what to do
with for all of these you can put the
those definitions into catalogs you can
add metadata so that you can find the
thing that you're after you can create
pipeline super trivially by using the
API that you already know or by using
this special Doge transform and tab
completion to look around all of the
conversion uh utilities that intake
provides for you intake can call
anything it's not par it has a load of
Integrations with specific things but
adding other
function calls is really easy you saw a
definition of one reader you can
trivially write this for any third party
package that you care to use this
Simplicity is what I hope will bring
people to intake um you don't need to
really understand intake deeply in order
to be able to build readers data types
converters output nodes all of this
stuff is usually just a few lines of
code you can uh add them into separate
packages or or and have them
automatically imported by intake it's
all really easy and this is why I
encourage people to get involved and try
it out already we have lots of types we
have lots of data types we have lots of
readers we have lots of converters this
is the current view of our transform
conversion Matrix web thing graph if you
like and you can see well you probably
can't see there's a lot of stuff on here
um for those of you with a good memory
this might look familiar to um the
package called Odo that was only about
transforming from one particular file
type to another particular file type
here we're transforming between apis and
file types and in data representations
like this
I oops back this lot here is probably
data frames this lot here is probably
X-rays I can't even read this at the
moment this this slot here is probably
erase I don't
know okay um catalogs can refer to other
catalogs so you can build up all of your
your data sets you can find them you can
search these things you you can encode
all of your your data um set of sets
into a a declarative thing you can save
those things into uh yaml or or a
service you can use templating you can
um have intake fill in your credentials
for how to load a thing using um
function calls or environment variables
or uh globally
defined um configuration values uh the
metadata can contain lots of useful
information you can search through these
things in a number of different ways you
can create intake cataloges that work
well in intake from other services the
simplest thing being hey these are all
of the SQL tables that I can see on my
SQL Server it's an obvious thing to do
but there are lots of ways to
automatically produce catalogs and then
search them the final point is though
all of this is going to work with people
get involved intake is interesting if we
have lots of types of data in catalogs
we have lots of catalogs and we have
lots of readers and lots of workflows so
when people get involved and start
producing cataloges and sharing those
cataloges that's when intake really
becomes interesting so this is a call
for people to get involved and once we
get over this initial hurdle of getting
people using intake then things will
start to look really
nice okay um I mentioned these things
already so I'm just going to mention it
again because it's kind of important
compared to other things in this
landscape intake does not store your
data you have to put your data somewhere
uh that might be in the cloud it might
be on your local network storage it
could be anywhere it could be an API
call it there's lots of ways to get your
data intake does not get your data it
just calls things to get your data
intake has no server but it interacts
really nicely with servers that expose a
catalog like API we don't have a flashy
website you don't need to register this
is open source always will be uh we just
live on GitHub um if you have some
Enterprise data system intake an
interface with that but we're not going
to provide you with authentication we're
not going to provide you with security
guarantees if you have a data system you
can use its security guarantees and have
intake as the interface to it um and
making catalog should be much easier
than it was in the
past okay again this is Alpha get
involved let me know what you think uh
things will change more will come uh
watch this space in particular we'll do
all of these things here more readers
more converts
graphical things so that the demo
doesn't look quite so dry uh other
catalog providers will be integrated
with and all the things that currently
work with V1 will eventually work with
V2 and that's it so I've left five
minutes for uh
questions um if there are no questions
then I'll see people in the discourse or
um find me on GitHub or wherever else
try out thank you very much great thank
you so much Martin that was great um yes
we do have a couple of questions um I'll
just the first one here I'll put on
screen for you are writing capabilities
in the road map for intake two Beyond
reading
capabilities yes intake already has some
output nodes so you can do a simple path
like read CSV right to par you can have
that as one of your pipelines uh there
is an an example in which you can use
this as as a a version of persisting
your data locally and reading from local
in the the locally efficiently stored
paret version of your data instead of
the original CSV as a as a caching layer
you you can do all those things yeah uh
there aren't too many output nodes yet
but it's a
design uh decision that you can do this
and we just need to write a few line of
lines of code for each of
them great thank you
and there is another question as well
how do you see intake how do you see
intake Compares or integrates with
commercial cataloges like data breaks
Unity catalog or open source ones like a
mson or Apache
atas yeah so it's a pretty busy
landscape there's lots of things and
many of these things particularly data
broks is of course then tied in with
your execution framework your using
spark your data is stored in in one one
of the things that data breaks
understand so probably S3 or there's a
some options there um intake wants to be
very agnostic and and
simple and it wants to provide
integration to these things so the um
Atlas I've looked at Amon I don't know
uh Atlas has a nice API you can see what
data you have uh defined in there and
you can expose that as an intake catalog
alongside all of your other things so
intake can be the layer over the top of
all of these things if you already have
it say a data break that is commercial
like you mentioned if you do all of your
processing within data blocks and you
already have a functioning catalog that
works for you that's fine there there's
no problem with that but intake wants to
be uh simple and not tie you into uh any
of these things